something leads here and my legs get in
a little better every day thank you for
the concerns in fact I'm with my some
friends right here but there's four
things that I learned from busting my
leg in that I just feel like I have to
share so number one and this is when you
have a problem whether that's a problem
in property in business or with a broken
leg to share the burden you know so for
me sharing the burden look like I
actually posted on when the doctor said
to me you'll never walk properly again
which is what he said instead of just
actually posted it on my facebook I
shared the burden with like 5,000 other
Facebook friends and said the doctors
just told me I'll never walk properly
again but I'm believing for a miracle
and I had over 150 stories posted under
the thing saying all told the same thing
mate I'll be fine you know people saying
some of them were miracle stories why
even even you know and you are by the
way qualified because your job is what
you're a stuntman who's been in movies
like how are you part of the Caribbean
meeting famous people so you know I burn
and I think that in property let's say
you've got a problem let's say your
problem is young got pouty in an area or
you haven't got money or you haven't got
this young instead just think if I
haven't what it's all just suffering
solace share it why say hey guys I've
got this problem and share
and share the burden I am super
important is in them interesting
questionnaire but I think a lot of
people do the exact opposite
yeah even with their close friends like
if they have a problem they'll just go
quiet let me call them the silent
sufferers and silent sufferers will
always lose you know I can't tell you
how many times I've solved my own
problem by talking to someone else
yeah yeah there was something there yeah
they were you sounding boy
number two because there's four there's
four lessons number two is and you know
this is cliche man here all the time but
I think it's really important is to be
really positive to keep positive like if
you if I chose to believe the doctor
saying I'll never walk properly again
then that would become a reality
you know when I'm lying in the hospital
bed in Uganda you know stock 25 percent
board loss told that I might have a head
injury but ah stands aren't working so
we'll pray to Allah for the best I've
got a choice I can either be like oh my
goodness I'm dying or I can say I'm
gonna get back I'm gonna you know and
you mental attitude affects your
physical affection it's just as I'm a
team passing you know to keep positive
what you need about to do that you know
number three is to seek counsel and what
I mean by that is to to find the best
people in in a particular field experts
and meet them and ask them questions for
me that was the case then finding expert
surgeons and asking them questions and
okay they were helpful when I was in
Uganda
I was messaging English doctors and
stuff with a limited white hat and they
were like get back to the UK when I got
back to the UK had cost me like ten
thousand pounds my ticket they said that
if I hadn't have got back then they
reckon on about three days and live in
dead so because I'll seek counsel you
know and again they surprised it
oh hell like business you know I'm a
mentor I'm a property mentor I'm people
come and seek my counsel and they're
smart for doing that and find people
that got the answers if you want to get
on in life find people that have done it
fine people that learn the answers and
then be a sponge and getting answers and
at some point so what we do we keep each
other's brain laughter there
the last one is just me yeah you know
you're responsible for your own life
you're responsible for your own destiny
no no doctor
the doctors inside will give you a
physio but unless you make it happen and
work hard and apply and implement you
know make it happen what happen when I
go to the hospital because in Uganda
third-world hospitals they don't look
after you they just treat you you know
so that I feed you they just expect what
you should have family in people so
there's no food there's it's very
different from English hospitals and
they it's a bit embarrassing but anyway
I wet myself and I was in my own urine
in bed for hours calling
nurse nurse you know bums around after a
series of events like that and feeling
really kind of neglected the hospital
the the the way they treat my leg
amazing but the nurses in what I did and
this would work in England but I said
caught according a couple of the nurses
and the doctor said oh I needed the
toilet I'd been waiting for hours called
a nurse the nurse came in I said I
needed toilet kind of was something and
she said we'll give you yeah they were
the clinic
you know yeah and I was like what do we
into it you little Brit and I'm like as
if
the bottle just my box or our wings
that's one just she when she came back
ages later with a condom so like serious
so I kind of try I'm a big pain and the
knees busting I'm right you know in a
bad way so we need to the condom and it
doesn't work and he goes everywhere so
anyway what I did what I did what I said
whose wouldn't work in England I said I
said I called some people in I said do
you know almost swartz [ __ ] is that's
it yeah I said yeah my friend when I
showed a picture on my phone at meet
Arnold Schwarzenegger do you know still
mr. Stallone it yep my and I went
through these pictures of means that
he's been there and and said you need to
look after me because I've got people
coming from England that will be here in
a week or so you know and now in England
if I did that I'll look minimalistic a
little bit like whatever you do but in
Africa there are respectable persons and
was this high rocky thing so women if
that they then put a nursery in my
bedroom 24/7 and I told her I'd buy a
smartphone if she did but it's just
interesting yeah you know the whole
story of how that happened but they did
look after me I go back to the UK but I
think that's it I think just you know be
positive share the burden I couldn't
share the burden when it first happened
because muscle one that walk on I didn't
want to tell people how bad it was and
then mess up their week and them out to
come back so I said you know I was a
silent suffering on the boat
time so I knew you you saw my kneecap
come open and bones everywhere but he
plays doubt you play because we wanted
to carry on and I was a solid sufferer
we decided that I was a bit of noise
when I found out what I said how bad the
edge we was yeah I played it down but
uhm so yeah so thanks for all you do and
I reckon I'm gonna get a full recovery
but even if not you know do whatever it
takes I'm gonna be doing why then took
this on some people said if you catch me
in crash courses until you get better on
one no because I do whatever it takes
and I'm so passionate about one mission
which is I'm financially free right your
thing is if I haven't if I'm not in a
good financial situation or to not be
able to afford the ten thousand five
ticket time the operation cost me three
thousand pounds like the whole thing
probably costing about 16,000 pounds up
until now just just to get back safely
to England after the accident now for me
that's no big deal for some people I
don't want anybody to be in this
situation you know so there's freedom
which is living life on your terms so
that's good yeah god bless you guys
peace out I'll see you thank you so much
for watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time